hi Brian thanks a lot for your question
in terms of things happening today it's
2858 January I cannot but refer to the
events unfolding in EJ we're very
important thing there's a demand for
much greater openness transparency and
accountability the broader population as
we have seen from countries around the
world over the last 20 years and wrong
and what is rather disturbing is that
instead of that quest on the general
population for more openness
transparency and accountability being
heeded we are seeing currently severe
repression further cut down of social
media landlines etc by the regime I
think this is very short-sighted because
in the long run the demand of the
general population for more
accountability for more openness for
more transparent governance will only
increase and longer regimes around the
world take to heed that call the more
repression suffering unnecessary deaths
will have so I hope that's very soon
governance around the world will realize
that the quest for more coconuts more
transparency cannot be stopped it is
irreversible and that every team that
corners thanks a lot